I think that's one of the biggest
benefits of going alcohol free it's
actually facing everything life's got to
throw at you with that clear head and
knowing that you can deal with it and
knowing that you don't have to run away
and ultimately understanding that the
fear of facing it is more severe than
the pain of actually facing it yeah you
know what I mean it's like the
anticipation uh that builds that creates
all that anxiety around facing that
thing you don't want to face when you
finally just face it 99 times out of 100
you're like why it wasn't that bad
exactly and then you build that
confidence that self-efficacy that
actually you know what I can deal with
all of these things I can deal with the
stress or the you know whatever the job
loss or the the funeral or the the death
without alcohol you know but I think for
so many people it's become so ubiquitous
in our lives that for every occasion
there's an excuse to have a drink if
it's you know to socially or commiserate
so you hit no not even one drink you
haven't had almost 5 years no and why
would I